vous souvenez vous que le 25 janvier
dernier l'institut pasteur avait annoncé
renoncer à ses recherches sur le vaccin
contre le coronavirus et sanofi accusent
des retards
contrairement à leurs confrères
allemands britanniques les scientifiques
hexagonaux n'ont malheureusement pas
réussi à élaborer un vaccin mais si en
fait les chercheurs de la start-up
franco autrichienne va deneva ont bien
remporter ce défi
mais la prouesse de cette société de
biotechnologie dont le siège social se
trouve à saint-herblain en banlieue de
nantes a été peu commenté leur vaccin vl
à 2001 est pourtant entré dans sa
troisième phase d'élaboration pour une
commercialisation à l'automne 2021 a
mais pas pour nous pour nos amis
britanniques et c'est l'histoire d'un
véritable fiasco français qui se dessine
la start-up franco-autrichienne produit
en effet ces vaccins en écosse grâce à
un investissement massif du royaume uni
le pays lui a confié plus de 1 milliard
400 millions d'euros somme indispensable
à son projet 60 millions de doses seront
donc livrés aux britanniques avant la
fin 2021
le risque financier pour londres et est
grand puisque le pays ne récupérera pas
ses deniers
si les essais cliniques ne sont pas
concluants mais qui ne tente rien n'a
rien ou pas grand chose et c'est le cas
de la france nous devrons attendre au
moins jusqu'en janvier 2022 pour avoir
accès à ce vaccin franco autrichien et
c'est regrettable car il est un des
rares conçu sur le principe des vaccins
classiques à base de virus inactivé il
pourrait séduire une partie de la
population
rebutés par les vaccins arn messager
alors pourquoi avons nous laissé passer
l'occasion en or d'être plus autonome
sur la vaccination
cette start up était pourtant digne de
confiance après avoir créé un vaccin
contre l'encéphalite japonaise et elle
est sur le point de commercialiser un
sérum contre le chikungunya en juin 2020
la présidente les républicains de la
région pays-de-loire christelle
morançais avait contacté la ministre de
l'industrie au sujet de vannes et 20
quelle belle fille de voir partir cette
belle pépite ailleurs en tant que
président de la région des pays de loire
forcément avec est une une grosse grosse
déception
et selon agnès pannier runes hr cette
ministre interpellé sur la question
la france a répondu présent nous leur
avons fait une proposition de soutien à
hauteur de 80%
ils ont préféré passer un accord avec le
royaume uni
le directeur général de vale neva franck
grimaud évoque pour sa part la proche
holistique des britanniques
leur réactivité aux demandes de soutien
eux qui furent les premiers à sortir le
chéquier avant juillet 2020 y aurait-il
eu d'autres points de blocage côté
français certains évoquent le fait que
veulent les va disposer déjà d'une unité
de production en écosse et que le
ministère souhaitait une production
locale
mais à l'heure de l'autoproclamé start
up nation certains élus ont du mal à
avaler la pilule on avait sous notre nez
une start-up que les britanniques ont eu
prise au sérieux c'est la démonstration
du small is beautiful
à la fin de la crise il faudra poser la
question émane une macro et à son armée
de spécialistes qui grouillent dans les
administrations qu avez vous réussi on a
voté il y a deux mois une loi de
programmation pour la recherche qui ne
sert à rien elle n'incite pas à la prise
de risque et ne permet pas un pilotage
étatiques dans des secteurs stratégiques
comme la santé un malheur n'arrivant
jamais seul valnet va n'a pas trouvé
d'accord global de vente avec l'union
européenne
après six mois de négociations
infructueuses la start up va négocier la
distribution de son vaccin pays par pays
et cela affectera le prix des doses
cette expérience en dit long sur
l'efficacité de la gestion centralisée
de la fourniture de ces roms organisée
par la commission européenne
et comme dit l'adage nul n'est prophète
en son pays ou dans sa communauté